we had a few questions come in from our
YouTube viewers and this one is from ms
green and she writes how has what you've
seen over time changed your view of life
and does it ever show up in your filming
or do you edit it out oh I think the
films I'm making are definitely starting
from my experience and a lot of them
have to do with how I'm questioning how
we're operating in this human experience
at all
so with frame by frame I there was just
so many questions I was having as a
storyteller about our perception and
where that comes from and one of the
make a film about Afghan photographers
to talk about perception of a place that
is so often this unknown known in a lot
of ways and with on her shoulders I was
really interested and I mean this is
kind of feeding off of that in a way
where it was continuing telling a story
about storytelling and the repetition
and the packaging of stories of trauma
and how we're receiving that as an
audience and our own relationship with
apathy and empathy through these stories
and so I don't think I would ever make a
film where I already had the answer I
already feel very strongly about things
like cigarettes or single-use plastic
and I don't think I would ever make a
film about it because I already know how
I feel about it
I think all of these films are questions
that I'm also asking myself and I think
that's maybe where the energy comes from
and and relates to an audience asking
themselves questions - um I think that's
where it all comes from is my own
questioning of life and how I'm
experiencing the world yeah where does
your love for storytelling come from I
mean you had gone you said to study
marketing for and I can see why and it
sounds like you took your love of the
environment and or different things and
wanted to add that to your marketing
plan
whatever but where does your love for
storytelling in film come from I
definitely have loved making videos
since I was a kid I I don't know it's a
hard question to ask where does my love
for storytelling come from because I'm
having a such a complicated relationship
with storytelling even now after making
on her shoulders and really questioning
where we're coming from the storytellers
and our responsibility to our subjects
and who's telling what story and and and
why we're telling it and all sorts of
different things so it's an interesting
space to be and now I know that I don't
want to stop this work and I will
continue to make documentaries and
probably die with a camera in my hands
but I don't even know where that comes
from
I think I have no idea I think I feel
like each film I make though is kind of
a exploration of things that I'm
questioning about life it's a process of
pulling things out of myself and
answering hard questions so it's a it's
I just love the process of it I love all
of that and of course it takes me to and
just introduces me to people that I
would never have met and I mean it's
such an honor to have met Nadia even
though I wish of course that I would
never have met Nadia I wish none of this
would have ever happened and she was
just still you know an unknown person in
a village in Sinjar but I am so so
thankful that I got to meet these people
and be exposed to their patience and
grace and empathy so I can see the world
in a different way it's a quite a gift
and hopefully that's translated to the
audience too